whoo oh geez hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to flicks and
chill to Millennials now a while ago I
played a game called Netflix and chill
but then this game is a full release
actually a full sequel after the full
release of that game but I thought I'd
skip to this one just to get something
new in here because the other one was
more in line with the first game episode
1 Melanie hi Melanie
my name is markiplier I feel like we're
gonna be hand-in-hand love and love like
and like oh my god I hope they're
wearing masks oh this is where you can
definitely find me at the club getting
it on Wow win our first rave never mind
I thought it was a club that's how far
off I am I know
oh isn't it awesome we're really living
the dream okay first order of business
get some dick find Tristan and John oh
do we have to uh [ __ ] bells guys come on
win do we have to can't we just let them
find us we only met them the other day
can we go and meet new people instead
yeah that's more like it
no way we need to make sure we get to
them before the other girls do come on
all right then let's find a ball
all right is that them right there right
next to you whoa it is - here
hello fellow young people are you up for
the dancing I've been known to boogie
down every once in a while
hello hi there hey what's going on
ladies Melanie what are you what are you
doing sorry my voice got really rough
for a second there I like your hair
thanks Mel come on let's go sorry she's
not interested in whatever you're
selling even though I like to jump
dancing that's pretty much my preferred
method of dancing all right fine God all
right geez whatever your name is that
can't even remember what my best
friend's name is hello hi how are you
she's the right people it's me Melanie
tristin John Melanie we're gonna say
each other's names endlessly hey ladies
we wanted when you guys were gonna gear
oh please we always arrive fashionably
late to the party you guys having fun
for sure that would be more fun with a
little bit of booze you guys want to get
some drinks before we do a bit of Janson
we already got started we're already
halfway through the dance spiel maybe
later on sure but nothing alcoholic
that's for me anything alcoholic will
literally kill me do that sure but
nothing alcoholic I don't like drinking
a rave
well I want something delicious sure
I'll go grabs it before us hold on me
and Melanie we'll go grab something
don't we know where someone needs to
keep you okay all right
sure why not I mean someone's got to
keep you out of trouble
that's why I love you Mel let's go BFFs
off to the bar hippity hoppity whoo
buddy whoo all right so boy howdy it is
bumping in this club okay never mind it
just stop bumping in the club
hey there excuse me we'd like stop what
are you doing I'm getting drinks you
don't buy drinks Melanie you're a pretty
girl what are you talking about didn't
you just offer to get the guys drinks
I'm kind of confused right now I'll take
the guy on the left you the guy on the
right what are you talking about just
follow my lead we're not paying for any
drinks tonight
all right sure hey is that young me hey
handsome oh ho hi hi there hello thanks
hey I'm gonna buy my own drinks why
would I have someone else pay for my
drinks that's ridiculous excuse me
bartender can I get a Oh Melanie you
won't believe the joke David just told
me that it's funny and it's about Let's
Plays
[Music]
oh stop it you're too funny
who's your friend David he's cute this
is great great Gramma's Graeme my
right-hand man ha ha hey hey Graeme uh
have you met Melanie
hi there yeah i'm graeme nice to meet
you I don't need you I have a boyfriend
I have a boyfriend I have a boyfriend
good to meet you however Whitney and I
were just leaving
what are you talking about David was
just about to buy me a drink
Whitney I don't know Oh fine bartender
what can I get you I want a cranberry
soda just get a cranberry soda Thanks
actually we only have red punch blue
punch or yellow punch oh okay
take the red punch me red then and a
blue for my friend John Thanks
here you go thanks a bunch hey before
you go I just want to say you have a
really cute smile oh thanks I'm not
coming on to you sweetie don't worry I
just on the lookout for a model for my
blog and you're like super pretty would
you be interested in helping out that
sounds really sketchy for your blog game
you need a model no but a hard pass on
that one sorry not really it's cool no
worries enjoy the drinks all right be
around thanks hey we'll be right back
gotta go see our friends real quick
let's go Mel winnie is a meanie pool
what are you doing sashay in your hips
like that
ah that was a blast I don't know I don't
really feel like taking advantage of
people like that oh please we're doing
those guys a favor they'll feel a little
more confident now that some girls
approached them and have a great time
because of it I don't know any Oh
oh quit your whining and let's just let
let's dance ah yeah okay okay I'm a
dancing is that we dance oh yeah gonna
get whiplash oh yeah ow ow well that was
some fun dancing you Millennials might
what the f you think you're doing we
talked about this Mase I'm dancing with
melody whinnies your girl hey what's
your problem just dancing where I'm
dancing don't be an arse ain't being an
arse you're being an arse well then why
don't we let her decide herself sounds
gonna be Chum Melanie do you want to be
AI will die no I don't remember who's by
myself and not being bartered for this
man either
I think I'm gonna sit this one out why
don't you tube dance together for a
while to settle your differences I keep
tellin Melanie I think we all need a
break I'm gonna dance over there for a
while pieces where they good clean me
all right goodbye see you around is
weird go over here hey how's it going
Mel huh yeah you like to dance now
Melanie dance with me
I'm trying sure let's do it of course
right by the speaker so we can go down
ah melv is so much fun see we don't need
no stinky boys to have a good time
that's what I was saying from the
beginning literally the first thing I
said totally right hell yeah we can have
fun just us girls
ah you know Melanie there's something
about you you make me feel good well
what do you mean I mean I feel good
around you don't you feel it too not
really just felt a lot of uncomfortable
what I mean
yeah hey you know fill it - you make me
feel like anything's possible you're so
much fun huh oh come on you're making me
blush now just dance further away uh
you're great the star finger gun Ernest
you back up all right let's go back to
meet up with the group yeah you're right
those boys probably don't know what to
do without us right now all right boy
they are angrily deep singing hey you
boys you boys all right over here your
boys all right how you doing boys
Melanie come on there we go
all friends totally platonic no need for
emotions that's what the hell Oh careful
there Mel
I thought I saw time slow down a second
you that was a close one thanks John you
can let go of me now you can let go of
me now oh yeah sorry glad you're okay
jeez what was that about yeah what's
your deal go see what's the map this is
some emotional dynamics I was not ready
for I'll go see what's the matter see
you guys have a go dance over this way
see what's wrong with Melanie hey Mel
how's it going
hey when what's up oh you're Winnie I'm
Melanie Derman and you're Winnie I'm
Melanie Oh Oh what do you mean what's up
you know fully well what's up
I really don't Winnie I thought you were
Melanie this hold huh did I do something
wrong no I fell do you need do you need
to get drunk
is this about Tristan this is about
Tristan how could you tell
I'm just so tired of giving them them
giving you all the attention I mean
aren't I cute too
let's see no no no see no way you're
gorgeous you're gorgeous
be serious Winnie you're gorgeous ha ha
la la la you're just saying that I mean
it mean it of course I mean it Winnie
you're my most beautiful friend by a
long shot
you're right I am beautiful and I don't
need any stupid guy to tell me anything
else yeah that's the spirit Winnie I
think I'm gonna dance by myself for a
while you know have some me time away
from these jerks feel free to come meet
up with me if you want thanks Melanie
you get it Winnie who is no longer
Melanie who are all these people here I
wish I could jump like you oh boy I am
having fun doodle doodle doo walking out
the front door don't eat any of this
bull I'm gonna go away now Oh what is
happening what's the deal here get drink
instead of dancing hey bartender have
some more red punch Thanks
okay gonna awkwardly stare for a bit I
[Music]
don't need nobody to tell me how to have
a good time ended up alone by the end of
it but I'm realizing I don't mind being
alone
hashtag independent look at all those
likes look at all those likes yeah get
it girl yeah witty what you are with
know your wind you are always winning
I'm Melanie haha take some of that Oh
silly
I liked it them that was fun I there I
don't know how many episodes there are
this is one is Melanie episode two is
Frank alright
so anyway there's more episodes to this
I don't think it's a very long game so
maybe I could play another episode if
you guys want to see it that was
entertaining just a lot of possible
options there some of them I don't know
just rubbed me the wrong way which is
why I just coasted by don't need no boys
don't need no girls don't need no
alcohol just need me and then I have a
good time by myself so that's nice so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought if you want
to see more let me know down in the
comments as well and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]